[音楽]この理解っていうのは
我々はどんな感覚を感じながら
相手にどんな感覚を与えるかというとこなんですね
そこでどんな人間でも楽しい感覚を受けたいということは当たり前
常識で それには証拠は要りません
ね 楽しい感覚欲しいと
足が痛いよりは痛くない方がいいでしょうしね
ですから 食べるご飯はまずいよりは美味しい方がいいでしょうしね
だから楽しい感覚は期待するということはもう決まってるんです
しかし 人間には楽しい感覚のみ味わうことは不可能です
全部苦楽 不苦不楽っていうのはごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃで
それで苦の苦の感覚 苦しい感覚が多い人は人生は不幸やという
楽の感覚はそっちがある人は幸せやと思っている
不苦不楽の感覚はある人はつまらない
つまらないとまた落ち込んだりする
そんなもんで だから我々の計算もすごい大雑把で
例えばあなたは幸福ですか？あるいは不幸ですかと言ったら
私は幸福だよと言っても
はっきりした計算じゃないんですよ
私の人生不幸だよという人も
人生いっぺんに不幸というわけじゃないんです
楽しいこといっぱいあったんですよ
でもそれは計算に入れないで
苦しいいくつかの出来事だけ計算して不幸だと言うんですね
ですから 人間インタビューして
あなたは日本人に生まれてよかったと思いますか？よかったと
そんなのは全然当てにならない話ですよ
もうあなたの人生は幸福だと思いますかと
あなたは人生は満足 満足ですよと
そんな一つも当てにならないいい加減な話なんです
みんなこの各感覚をちゃんと計算して言ってるわけじゃない
ただ一部印象強い何か何か覚えて言うだけで
例えば一生幸福な人であろうとも
突然ものすごい不幸なことにあったとしますね
それは突然のほんのわずか瞬間の出来事
でもそれはあまりにも印象が強かったら一生苦しむんですよ
例えば地震を受けたんですね
それでいきなり1日ですごいショックを受けちゃったんですね
でもその苦しみっていうのは
まあ人が亡くなっても亡くなって
それでももう別にそれからもういないんだからね
普通の生活ができるんですが
やっぱりそのインパクト強いんですね
親しい人が死んじゃったっていうこと
家が壊れたっていうことがね
で 避難生活は 1年もプレハブで生活したんだとかね
そのもう短い時間のインパクト強いんだから
それからずっと あの 何て言いますか
ポストシンドローム それで悩んじゃうんですね
だからそれが正しい論理的じゃないんですよ
たとえ自分の子供が死んだとしたっても
それは一時的な出来事で
ずっと子供を抱いたままで生活したわけじゃないし
で 別々に生活していたでしょうし
それでやっぱり亡くなったらショックなんですよ
で それがインパクト強くなっちゃうと忘れなくなくなっちゃうんですね
子供死んでから15年 20
年生活しちゃっても もう不幸で不幸で不幸でということになっちゃうんですね
それは我々のこの理屈足らないところから生まれてくるものなんですね
でも人間っていうのはそれほど強くないんだからね
そんな論理的にはならないところも当然なんですけどね
そう簡単に不幸な出来事を忘れちゃうということもできませんから
それは悲しいところなんですね
人生 人間としては ですから
この私は幸福ですかね
不幸ですかねと思う場合は
ずっと人生をね ちゃんと 1コマ1コマ考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
小さい時からもね そうするとあれは良かった
これはまずかった これは良かった
これも良かったとかね
これがまずかったとか
そうやって連続して幸福の連続が出てくるんですね
それがちゃんと見て引き算足し算でどちらの方が多いかと見た方がいいんですよ
そう見ると 人間の場合は苦よりは楽の方が多いと思います
人間の場合は 苦しみを味わった時間より
すごく楽しみを味わう時間の方が多いんです
で それあの この外国ではいろんな難民がいますね
ものすごい もう10年も15年ももう苦しくて
食べるものなくて 上でとかね
やっぱりそれでも頑固としっかりと生きていようとしているでしょ
爆弾あっちこっちからもう行ってるなのに
ここら辺は地雷埋めてるのに
それでもまあ飛行機から落とされた食べ物でも拾ってでも食べて
もう生活してます だからやっぱりそういう人々にしても
なんであれほどしつこく生きてきたがるんでしょうかというと
やっぱりどこかに楽しみがあるんですよ
で 例えば子供が殺されるということは
皆様には経験あることでもなんでもないんだけど
アフガンやらね もうそこら辺でもう考えられないでしょうね
もう三人殺されたら イスラエルではなくて
パレスチナにしたってもね
家族丸ごと殺されちゃったとかね
あるでしょうね それでも頑固と生きてますよ
だからね なんかわからないんですよね
どこかで何か期待とかね
楽しみとかね というのは感じています
でなきゃもう生きていられませんよ
この世の中で だから この我々のこのいい加減な大雑把な
私は不幸やとかね 私は幸福やとか
それはやめてほしい それはあまり知識的じゃないんですね
もっときちんと人生を見た方がいいんですよ
きちんと見てみると 幸福の方が多いんです
人間の場合は ですから
仏教では人間に生まれることはあの悪臭とは言ってないんです
天界と人間の世界はほぼ同じレベルで考えているんです
だから 神々として生まれることと
人間として生まれることも
それほど差がないと で
差があるといえば 神々とは霊的な存在だから
ご飯作ったりはしません
仕事をしたりはしません
それぐらいのことなんですね
人間というのは仕事をすること
ご飯作ったりすること
体洗ったりすることは大変な大仕事で考えているんだから
家を作ったりとかね だからやっぱり人間よりは天国に生きて生まれ変わりたいとかね
と思っているんですけど
それぐらいのことなんです
ね  それはそんな苦労じゃなくて
人間だから当たり前やと
仕事をすることやらね
あの家を作ることやらね
そんなのも人間で当たり前だと思っちゃえばね
天国とほぼ同じですよ
それよりも人間には智慧の開発はできます
霊になってくるとなかなか難しいんです
それから物事を理解することもできるし
自分の生命として輪廻脱出することもできるんだから
人間に生まれることはものすごいチャンスやと
とも言ってます ですから
人間に生まれたこのチャンスを逃してはいけないんですよ
それが食うための人生だから
もうあまりにももったいないんですよ
ずっと食べることをどうしようかという
それで仕事だけのことしか考えていないんですね
そんなのはほんのちょっとのことで
ものすごく心清らかにすること
もう智慧を開発すること
これ人間にしかできないことだからね
それが見失っては見失ってはならないとというのは
仏教の言い方というかね
よく言うことなんですね
だから仏教徒という人々は
あまり文句を はない 例えば雨が降らなくても食べ物は少なくなったと
別にあまり気にしない
そんなことは あるものは分けて食べましょうと
昔テレビでNHKで見たんですけど
ミャンマーでこのお母さんがね
子供がものすごい貧しくてね
子供はちょっとした病気になったとか
死んじゃうんですよ そんなにすごい田舎で貧しいところで
で それで別に何のことなく
悲しいこともなく 子供を埋葬して
それなりに供養して それでどうです？悲しいでしょうか？とインタビューされたら
まあ死んだ時は悲しかったんだけど
まあそれは別にその子供の業でしょうしと
ですから まあその子の業だから
まあ早く亡くなったんであって
まあ生まれ変わったところでも幸福にいてほしいと
私は 私はまあ供養しましたと
まあそれしかできることないんではないかと言って
僕 普通にそんなくよくよ泣いたりすることなく
普通に生きているんですね
ですから 仏教徒の世界では
この仕事がなくなったらどうしようかとかね
もうそういうくだらんことにはあまりエネルギーは使わないんです
誰かが亡くなったら その 1 日 2 日は悲しむ
悲しみますけど それでまあ
その人の将来のことを冥福を祈ってなんか供養でもしましょうと
それでもう忘れちゃうんですよね
その人の業ではないかと
なんで私に限ってそんなことになるかと全然思わないんですね
自分が重病になったって
まあこれは私の業だからとね
ということで それは問題にしないんですね
その代わりにもうさっさといいことをしておかなくちゃいけないと
ということで 心清らかにすることにやっぱり重点を置いておくんですね
だからどちらかというと結構明るいんですよ
私はびっくりしたのは
このタイのことをテレビで見たニュースを見たんですけど
洪水でもう全部家の屋根まで水が溜まって
みんなあっちこっちもう逃げてるんですね
ボートやらね 小さなボートに子供たちはみんな乗って遊んでるんですよ
笑いながら いろいろ遊びながら
誰一人も悲しいや大変顔をしてないんですね
なるほどなと思ったんですね
なんかどこかに遊び遊んでいるような
あの どうったことないと思う
別に洪水になったら私のせいということでもないし
まあもうそのうち水が減るでしょうだろうという感じで
そこで他の人々はそれなりにご飯を作ってあげたりとか
面倒見てあげたりするし
それもなんで私たちはこんな風に人のご飯をもらって食べなくこんな運命なの？そんな考えません
ありがとう おいしかったという感じで
すごく気楽に それであのボランティアする人々も
何のことなく楽しく ニコニコと穏やかで
もう結局遊びながら何でもやってますね
どんなことにしたっても
あまり大げさに考えない
それからこの性転換手術とかね
もうタイでもものすごい上手でしょっちゅうやってるみたい
外国からどんどん来る
もう値段も安いし なぜかというと
そんなこと全然気にしない
男が女になる あ そう 女になりたいのはいいよ
全然あんまりもう そんな大したことだと思わないというよね
そこはね やっぱりそのそれが我々はもうまだ原始的でね
発展してないととんでもない話なんですよ
本当は仏教の人々の思考ほど誰も優れてないんですよ
まだまだ原始的で 西洋思想なんか見てください
ちょっと何かあったらひどいでしょうね
状態は 例えば男で生まれたっても
私は女やと思う可能性いくらでもありますよ
過去世で女だったらどうしますかね
その習慣とか体に付いてるでしょうに
だから仏教というのは
それはあんた女と思ったら男で生まれたんだから男でやりなさいよと言うし
それでもダメや だったら女になれです
あんまりそれがもう家には良くないとかね
隠さなくちゃあかんとかね
そういう差別的な思考っていうのはない
まあ業だからね それぞれのそこで輪廻は認めていますから
もう必ずしも永久的に男性は男性で
女は女でいるっていうわけじゃないです
それはもうしょっちゅう変わっちゃうし
だから過去の経験で 過去の覚えでなんかちょっと不安を感じるっていうことはあると思います
とにかく赤ちゃんたちを見ると
えらいもう乱暴者でしょ
赤ちゃんっていうのは何もできないんですけど
まああれが嫌 これが嫌やとわがままで泣きばっかしで
管理は全くもう手に負えない
なんで泣いてるかさっぱりわからないとかね
やっぱり納得いかないんですよ
生まれたばっかしだから
過去世の 思い ものすごい強烈なんですよ
それでまるっきり何者か知らない人々の間で育てられると
もう機嫌が良くないんですよ
そこでゆっくりとゆっくりと
しょうがないです この人はすごい親切やと
お母さんのことはね 私が泣いちゃうとすぐ飛んで君はいらんだけど
すぐ飛んでくるんだと
なんとか慰めてあげようとする
それでゆっくりと納得いくんですよ
それでやっともう母だ父だと認めてくれるんですね
その時はもう家族がみんな楽しくて落ち着いてくるんですね
そこまでは大変なんです
ですから そんなのは輪廻考えちゃうと不思議でもなんでもないんです
兄弟でもものすごく仲良くなる場合もあるし
何の訳もなく とにかくえらい敵同士で喧嘩ばっかりする場合もありますよ
もうどうにもならん もうお母さんが困って困っていくら困ったっても
二人がうまくいかない
そういう兄弟もいるし
それは仏教の世界では全然問題にならない
母親が二人別れちゃう
もうお前らもう喧嘩するんだから
別々にやりなさいと 一緒にやるなよと
で 母は中間的で その人にも親切にしてあげて
この人にも親切にしてあげる
二人を合わせて一緒にすればしません
で わかったらそれで問題になりませんだからね
そこでお母さんと弟がお姉ちゃんのお姉
姉の文句を言っても もう悪いんではないかとか
そうと言って 全然犯人もうこの人に言って
またその人弟の愚痴ですよね
それを聞いて それで忘れちゃうと
あまりにも激しく言うとね
怒るんですね その場合は激しいことを
二人とも私が産んだんだからね
いい加減なことを言うなよと
私とどちらでも同じだよと
私も言われたんだから
喧嘩しちゃうとね で 弟が悪いんではないかと言ったら
もうそれは認めないんですね
そんなこと言うなよと
どちらでも同じだと 私には
と言っちゃうと もうそれで喧嘩で母に対してもあれできませんだから
弁論はね で もう落ち着きますけど
ですから やっぱり業っていうことが
輪廻っていうことがあって
その思考で生活すると
今現代人にあるあらゆる問題っていうのは何のことなく解決するんですよ
それにかかる時間とお金が全部もう儲かる
残るでしょうに だから今はもう家族の問題で
兄弟の問題で 会社の仕事の問題で一生時間なくなっちゃうんですね
だから誰にも暇もなくて
だからもうせっかく人間に生まれたこのチャンスなのに
もう食べることと生きることで精一杯というのはあまりにも良くないんですよ
もったいないんですよ
だからいろんな差が人間の間であるし
同じ家族でもあろうとも
やっぱり親言うことは聞かない場合もあるし
子供たちはね 親の性格とはまるっきり違う性格を持っている場合もあるし
そんなのは気に その人の道で
あんた頑張りなさいと
たとえエリートの家族の子供であろうが
まるっきり勉強は嫌いな子が生まれてくるかもしれませんし
自分が普通の労働で生活したいんだ
まあ勝手にやりなさいよと
それでいいんでしょうに
逆に私エリートだからね
あんたもちゃんとエリート学校に入って
エリートとして仕事をしなくちゃいけないと言ったっても
これで問題が起こるんですね
そうすると 親もものすごくお金を使わない
勉強したくない人に勉強させるということは
もう大変な仕事だから
どれぐらいお金がかかるかわからない
それで喧嘩は絶えないでしょうに
それでそういう強引にエリートにしたっても
親は恨むんでしょ 一生
結局もう子供やらね もうずっと仲良く楽しく死ぬまでいるっていうことはなくなっちゃうんですね
だから不幸になるんですから
業やら輪廻やらね そういう概念わからなくてもいいんですけど
でも業もない 輪廻もない
全部偶然だっていう馬鹿げた話
あるいは全部神が作ったという馬鹿げたいい加減な話よりはマシでしょうに
すごいすごい立派な思考でしょうに
だからわからないのは私もわかってますよ
これはもう知識では超えているものだからね
でも 実際の世界ではすごく便利な幸福をもたらす
落ち着く教えなんです
で それからすごく早く
それからお釈迦様はこの業論を説明してあげて
あのブッダの業についての分析っていうのは
人間にはもうわからないんだと言って
こういうことを説明するんですよ
この世の中で殺生したり
盗みを働かせたり 不丈夫不丈夫っていうんですか
よこしまな行為をしたり
嘘をついたり 酒麻薬を使ったり
そうやってもう悪をばっかりやっている人々はいるんだよと
そこで悪いことをやっているんだけど
死んじゃったところで
ものすごく天界に生まれ変わっちゃうんだ
また 何も罪を犯さない
殺生もしないし 泥棒もしないし
よこしまな行為もしないでしっかり生きているんだけど
死んじゃったらもう悪い不幸なところで生まれ変わるんだと
そのケース２つ そこでまた
殺生しないで悪いこともしないで生活していて
天界に生まれる人もいるんだと
それで殺生したり 悪いことしたりして
悪事を働いてして死んで不幸になる人もいますよと
ケース４つなんです 悪いことをして天界に生まれる人
悪いことをしたのにして
不幸に地獄に落ちる人
それはもう則的に取りましょう
悪いことをして生まれて死んで地獄に落ちた人と
良いことをして天界に生まれた人と
良いことをして地獄に落ちた人というケース４つがあります
それで修行者たちがいるんだと
この世の中で この人々は仏教ではなくて
他の宗教で出家して 一生懸命修行に励んで
この超越した智慧を得られるんだと
この過去を見られる能力
見られたと見られるところで
この特別な能力を得たところで
人々のことを観察すると
それでこれ発見するんですよ
ある行者が悪いことをしたにも関わらず
天界に生まれた人は見えちゃうんですね
何々さんが悪いことを生活していたんではないかと
なのに死んでから今はもう万々歳で天界にいるんではないか
自分の超越した知恵で見るんだと
見たらこういうことを言うんですよ
世の中でこの業っていうものはないんだと
いいことをしたって 悪いことをやってもどうったことないんだよと
だって私の超能力で私は何々さんのことを知ってますよと
その人がもう悪いことをしていたにも関わらず
今天界にいるんだよと
だから悪いことをしたっても
いいことは関係ないんだ
みんな天界に行くんだよと
としゃべる 説法する その説法する宗教家がいい加減なことを言ってるわけじゃないんです
自分の超能力で見て言ってるんです
それで彼がこう言うんですよ
もし人が悪いことに悪い結果があるんだ
いいことにいい結果があるんだというならば
あんなのはインチキ 嘘もいいところで
私が言ってることは 自分でここまで修行して
超越した智慧で超能力で見て言ってるんだから
私が言うことだけ正しいんだよと
徹底的に自分の考え方に執着する
そこでもう一人の修行者が
他の人をチェックしてみます
悪いことをして地獄に落ちた人が
なるほど 悪いことをしたら地獄に落ちるんだと
だから世の中でいいことをしたらいい結果になるでしょう
私は何々さんを見ましたけど
その人は悪いことをしていて
今は死んで地獄に落ちているんだと
で その人は私が言うことだけ正しいんだと
他の人々何言ったって
それは全くもういい加減なことで嘘だと
で 自分の考え方にしがみつく
次のケース 2つも同じで
良いことをしたのにも関わらず
地獄に落ちた人を見た修行者
修行者がやっぱり業はないんだと
あと 良いことをしたのに
今地獄に行っているでしょうにと
それで良いことした人は天国に生まれ変わっているのを見たら
あ やっぱり業があるんだそうと
そういう風に この 4種類の宗教家たちが業についてごちゃごちゃいろんなことを言ってますと
で お釈迦様 それ 4つまとめて
この場合でも気をつけて経典で書いてるところは
今私は省略して経典そのまま日本語で言ってるだけのことなんですけど
自分の解釈なしに あの
この業があるということ
行為によってどこかに生まれ変わるんだということは
人間の常識ではわからないんだよと
この変なことを言っている宗教者たちも
ちゃんと瞑想して ちゃんとした修行で
その超越した智慧を得て見ているところなんですね
だから仏教を認めないのは当然ですけど
仏教を認めない他宗教なんですけど
お釈迦様 この他宗教の人々もちゃんと修行して超能力を得て喋ってるんだよということはちゃんと認めるって認めているんです
いい加減に言ってるわけじゃない
本人の経験なんです だから
ちょっと宇宙飛行士で
ちょっと地球の軌道を回っただけで宇宙のことを語ると
まあそれぐらいのことを知ってるんですけどね
だからまあ 軌道にまで行ったことをちゃんと認める
それはもう無責任で否定しているわけじゃないんです
ですから 仏教は他宗教は批判しますけど
無責任でやっているわけじゃない
そのちゃんとした能力はそのままで認めます
そこでお釈迦様がこういうふうにそれをまとめるんですね
業 悪いことをしても悪い結果にならないんだから
業がないという あの思考は私は認めませんと
それから私が見たんだから
私が見たことが事実で
他の人言うことは間違いという
あの態度も認めませんと
すごい論理的なんですよ
私が見たものだけ正しいんだと
他の人言うことは認めませんというのはいい加減なことだから
その態度は認めませんと
そこで良いことをした人は天国に生まれたんだから
やっぱり業があるんだよという人の場合
お釈迦様はこう言うんです
やっぱり業があるんだよという二人いますね
この二人は私は認めますよと
考え方は でも 私が知っていることだけ正しくて
他の人々が言っていることはむちゃくちゃ認めませんという
あの態度は認めませんと
だから私が知らないんだから嘘やというのはあまりにもバカバカしい態度
仏教は認めません だから知っているものも知らないものも大勢たくさんありますから
それはしょうがない そこでなんでそうなるんでしょうかと
お釈迦様はさらに説明するんですよ
例えば 殺傷したり泥棒したり
あらゆる悪いことをした人が見ても
その人が今天界に生まれているんだと
でももしかすると その人がその悪いことをしていた時期ありますね
その以前 良い人間でいた可能性ありますと
人間というのは赤ちゃんから死ぬまで悪事やっているわけじゃないでしょうに
それ過去もありますから
ですから あの観察したあの宗教家が
この人は悪人だと判断したっても
ある時期で悪いことをしたんであって
この時間の軸で考えないと
例えば人２人殺しちゃったらもう悪人だと決めつけちゃうでしょうに
でもその人は年生きてるんだったら
人殺しに使った時間と人殺さないでいた時間と計算してみてみてほしいんですよ
例えば一生真面目に仕事をした人は一回失敗してたところで
一回ちょっと会社に言わないで
ちょっと１万円も持っていったところで
やっぱり横領したんだよと
まあ悪人と決めるのはまああまりよくないと我々思っちゃうんですよ
だから年夫婦やっても
一回裏切ったらもう裏切り者やもう離婚やと
というよりも やっぱり計算して考えた方がいいんですよ
何年自分を裏切っていたんですかと
何年自分に対して親切にしていたんですかとかね
それではっきりした結果が出ますけど
人間そういうことをやらないんですよ
年目の浮気もかなり効くんですね
そういうわけだから この悪人だと言ったってのも
赤ちゃんの時から死ぬ瞬間まで毎秒毎秒悪事だけやっていたんだという
これは成り立ちませんしね
ですから お釈迦様は言うのは
この人はその時期 そのピリオド以前に善行をした可能性あります
あるいはそのピリオド後
良いことをした可能性あります
それで一人が今刑務所にいる人なんですけど
弁護士から私にメールがありまして
あの 自分もこのもうかなり悪いことをした人で
どうにもならないんだと
でも 彼がヴィパッサナー瞑想やら仏教についてはすごく興味を持ってるんだと
で 刑務所でいながらでも修行はできるんでしょうか
なんとか一生懸命それは考えているんだよと
ですから このどうでしょうかとメールがあって
私は一応アドバイスを書いてあげましたけどね
で 書いてる途中で最後に
まあこれ 弁護士は関係ない人だからね
弁護士も真面目で 自分のクライアントの要求はなんとかしてあげようという気持ちは私は気に入ったんですね
ただ弁護するだけではなくて
それで私はあなたも大変立派な人ですよと
弁護するだけではなくて
人の心のところまで心配するということはすごく素晴らしいことだと
一行書いておいたんですね
それでそちらから返事があって
いえ 違いますと 逆にその人のおかげで私も仏教をそういうそういう教えがあることは知りましたと
アンゴリマールの話とかね
そういうことはその人のおかげで知りましたと
ですから まあそれはどちらかということじゃないんだよと
ですから 人を殺したんだから悪人だと決めつけても
その人がもしそれからずっと刑務所にいるかもしれませんし
誰とも話すことも何もできませんしね
でも その人は修行したらどうなると思いますかね
立派な行為を最後にやってますから
素晴らしいんですよ それを認めてあげないのは
我々が出来が悪いんだからであって
ですから そこら辺は大事に考えてほしいんですね
そこでお釈迦様が言うのは
この人 この悪事を犯したあとでも良いことをしたかもしれません
あるいは死ぬ時 死ぬ瞬間で
死ぬ間で心を清らかにして
正見 正しい智慧を持ったかもしれません
とにかく死ぬ時はサンマディティ正見あるならば
決して悪いところにはいきません
正見というのは頭がすごく整理しているということなんです
正見 正しい見解 こんなごちゃごちゃ変な思考じゃなくて
曖昧な思考じゃなくて
しっかりした正見あると頭が整理しているんですよ
そういう人はもう確実に生まれ変わるときはいいところに生まれるんですよ
もう整理しているんだから
人間に生まれたっても
ちゃんと DNA 正しく合わせてもらいます
その人 ですから その人は死ぬときは正見を持っていた可能性ありますと
それは見ないで いきなりある一つの出来事を見て
あ あの人いいところだったんではないかと
でも今天国にいるんではないかと
それでもう単純に単純に決めつけちゃうんだと
それでなぜ善行していても
ある人が地獄に落ちるんですかというところの説明に行きますけど
それはある時期でいいことをしていたんですけど
以前悪いことをした可能性ありますね
あるいは以後 この善行為をして
それからそれをやめちゃって
もう嫌になったぞとかね
それから悪いことをした可能性もあります
あるいは死ぬ間際になってきたら
もうなんだ もう全部うるさい
もう嘘やどうでもいいやとかね
すごく怒ったりして不満で死ぬ可能性あるし
時々ありますよ 一生すごいいいことをしているのに
もう死にかけてくると
がんになってくると 末期病になってくると
まあわがままでいい加減で
私はこんなにいい人間で生きてきたのに
なんで今更苦しまなくちゃいけないんだ
全部インチキは嘘やとかね
言って 今まで自分の行為を全部否定して
もう邪見に陥っちゃうんですよ
だったらもう年素晴らしい生活をしていたっても
死ぬ時は邪見だったらもう決まってます
行くところはそういうとこですよ
ですから このやたらに一般の人々にどこに生まれ変わるかっていうことも
どんな業で生まれ変わるかっていうことも
それはわからないもんで
あまりにも幅広い世界だから
もう人間の能力にはもう計算できないんですよ
例えば私が生まれた時から死ぬ瞬間までね
何秒何秒どんな行為してるか
それわかったもんじゃないんだから
で 覚えてる一つの出来事だけで
もう引っかかって あなたは悪人だ
あなたは善人だとかね
そう決めません 判断は決して無理
我々は悪も善ももうごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃそっちをやってます
判断したければ  １ 秒 １ 秒全部計算しなくちゃいけない
でもそれは事実上無理でしょうに
人間の能力では だったらやめてほしいということね
お釈迦様はそんな考え方はやめて
良いことをしなさい 正見を持ちなさい
正しいものの見方を持ちなさい
理性ですね 理性を持ちなさい
それで安全ではないかと
という業の分析という話はお釈迦様がしてあげたんです
それからこの皆様知ってますか？このどんな業か
例えば 良い仕事に恵まれて
収入が安定して それほど苦労ない方々もいるでしょう
それでも苦労して仕事しなくちゃいけないんですね
立派な気持ちのいい家で住みたいんだったら
やっぱり一生のローンでも組んでおかないとね
そういう人生でしょ 我々の人生は
幸福になりたければ その分苦労しなくちゃいけない
ですから 引き算でしてみると
なんかちょっとゼロというか
ちょっと割に合わないというかね
30年ローンを組んで
なんとかちょっとした家を建てたと
でもマイホームは好きで好きで
欲しくて欲しくてたまらなかった
それで頑張って作ったと
作ったりしたっても すぐとローンを払わなくちゃいけない
仕事は安定しているんですけど
仕事をするのは大変ですね
楽じゃない 家族はいるんだけど
もう大変疲れるんです
疲れてしまう 家族の面倒を見たりすると
子供たちがどこかに遊びに行きましょうと言ったら
子供を連れて日曜日は行きますけど
子供はすごく楽しくて遊んでももう遊んでいますけど
こちらはもう疲れて疲れて
だから子供と一緒に遊んで楽しいと
あるいはせっかくの休みで休んだ方がいいのに
その苦しみの方がどうかどうかね
それであなた方はお母さんと一緒に遊びに行きなさいと
私は日曜日だから寝るぞと言っちゃうと
自分が楽しく寝られますけど
逆に家族の結果どうなるかと
そうすると子供さえも自分の言うことを聞かなくなっちゃう
それで不幸になるでしょうし
ですから幸福になるためには苦労しなくちゃいけないといかないということがもう決まってます
人間の場合は どんな人にしたっても
それは何なのかね それでこういうことなんですね
我々にとっては楽と苦がごちゃ混ぜなんですね
苦なしに楽が生まれません
楽があったら 楽が先に味わったら次に苦が待っている
いきなり 例えば万円のダイヤのネックレスを買ってしまえば
気に入った もうどうしようもならない
もう買いますと言ったら
それから万円のローンが借金が襲ってくる
先に楽を得たんだから
あるいはずっと年も年もお金をちょっとちょっと貯めて
貯めて貯めて貯めて やっとネックレス買いますね
そうすると長い間苦労して
最後に楽が出てくると
どちらでも同じなんですよ
苦は楽にするか 楽は先にするかという
人生っていうのはそういうふうに
この苦楽のごちゃ混ぜ
それはどういうことかで
我々の業なんですよ 我々はこの過去世ででも前で行為をする時は
苦と楽とごちゃまぜの行為をしているんです
まあ例えば善行為で言いましょう
例えばまあ人ぐらい人々はこの避難生活をしているんだと
では 私はみんなに食事を作ってあげますと
二日間 いうと これ大変な仕事なんですよ
それで ああ 嫌だ 大変だ
買い物しなくちゃいけないんで
もうどうしようか もうどこを誰に頼んだ方がいいんでしょうか
もうもう食器どうしようかとかね
もうもう嫌やとかね そうやってもう嫌にもなるんですよ
決めたことをやることはやるんだけど
いつでも気持ちよく 穏やかで
二日間 人の避難生活する人々に気持ちよく
自分も完璧に気持ちよく
仕事も気持ちよくしてあげようといったら
人間の場合はこれはうまくいかないんですよ
例えば 米屋さんに米を注文したんだけど
そちらはもう今日は無理ですよと
品物入ってないんだから
明日はどうですかと と怒ってくるんですね
あなたからずっと買っているんではないかとかね
言ったら お客さん それはそうなんです
それはもう週間で十キロぐらいでしょうしと
これは一日一回でこれぐらいと言っちゃうと
私は約束 いろんな家に約束してるんだから
それを配らないといけないんだと
あなたに米あげちゃうと
全部お客さんがダメになりますから
これは無理ですよと と向こうは言うでしょうね
こちら怒ってしまうし
だったらベストな米屋さんに頼むそうとか
あなたとはもう商売これからはやりませんとか
それは怒りでしょうに
だから ある面で自分が一生懸命約束
約束した仕事をしたいんですが
その過程でもう怒りも出てくるわ
落ち込みも出てくるわ
あらゆること苦しみが出てきますね
ですから 米屋さんには米屋さんを必ずしも困らせちゃったんですよ
そのケースでは 米屋さんもどうにもならない
長い間のお客さんでしょうし
ですから もう言うことは聞いてあげたいんですけど
自分にもお客さん一人じゃないんだから
たくさんいるんだから
みんなの要求をちゃんと満たしてあげるのが自分の仕事でしょう
でもこの人はうるさくていろんなことを言うし
だからって怒り返すわけにもいきませんしね
だから米屋さんはものすごく鈍足に悩むんでしょう
だから 自分がいいことをしながら
誰かをどん底に悩ませてるんですよ
それで我々はいいことをしたっても
なんかごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ悪いこともやってるんです
一緒に その結果なんですよ
人間に生まれたら まあ混ぜてます
空も楽もし純粋にこの善行為をしたならば
結果はすごい綺麗なんです
苦なし楽だけ入ってくるんです
だから別にもう文句言わないで頑張った方がいいと思います
それはもう生まれる前に行った行為の割り当てなんですよ
だから いいことをする時は
悪い人に見栄をかけたの方が重かったら
こちらでもたくさん苦労して
やっと幸せということになるんですね
五分五分だったら五分五分で
計算はすごくぴったし合って結果が出てきます
因果法則だから それはごまかしはないんです
業っていうのは一応そんなもんです
それで仏教は推薦するのはそういうわけで
もしいいことをしようと思ったら
気をつけて気をつけて
心を汚れないように 米屋さんには 100キロを注文したんだけど
もう無理ですよ ああ そうですか
それはそれは まあそういえばそうでしょうね
実はこういうことをやってますから
申し訳ない 突然の注文で何か知り合いの方々からでも助かりますからね
集めてくれませんかとかね
いいことですよ そちらもちょっと頑張った方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
そうやって相手もすごく気持ちよくしながら
で いろんな邪魔が入りますよ
どんな邪魔が入っても
自分の心だけは汚れないように気をつけて頑張ることはいいんじゃないかなと
そうすると自分が行った行為がすごく綺麗で綺麗な結果にはなります
それから業と結果でちょっと割に合わない部分もあります
例えば こんついで人を殺したならば
これはもうもう死刑で終わっちゃいますね
それで十分償ったことになりますかね
自分が人を殺した それで裁判で自分も殺されるようになると
そこは結果ですよ 悪いことの
でも全部受けたわけじゃないんです
ほんのわずかなんですよ
だって法律で人を殺す場合は
随分丁寧で日にちちゃんと決めて
その間は随分楽をさせてあげて
欲しいものもなんだかんだも聞いてあげて
丁寧に殺すんですね 本人も覚悟した上で
でも自分が殺した場合はどうですかね
突然でしょうに だから人を処刑したっても
それでもう償った そういうことにはなりません
それで悪いところはもっとひどいところ
そこじゃないんですよ
で 人を殺した人が その混乱した心で死ぬ時もそれを思い出すでしょ
なんで私は今処刑になっているんでしょうかと
人を殺したんだからと
そのイメージからは心は逃げられません
ちゃんと瞑想したりしちゃうとね
まあイメージは解決できますけど
普通は今前の例に出した人みたいにやらないんだから
誰もね こういう方法があるということさえも世界は知らないんだからね
ちゃんとした論理的な科学的な教えがあるということさえも知らないしね
教えようとすると邪魔ばっかりするし
それは余計な話で で それそのイメージが頭に浮かぶでしょ
死ぬ瞬間で それ その人の次の命が
その心が構成するんですよ
それからその体で一生苦労しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それで一生苦労しちゃうと
楽しみ 喜びっていうのは味わったことがない
それでずっと嫌な心で
嫌な心で一生いて 最後にも嫌な心で死ぬ
そうすると次も同じくなっちゃう
だからほんのちょっと罪を犯しても
結果はあまりにもたくさんですよ
それは一般人にわかりやすくこう言うんです
仏教は一人の人の首を飛ばしちゃうと
あなたは無双にあなたの首を飛ばしますよと
それはもうちゃんとした話なんですけど
それだけ持ってくるとわからなくなるだけで
ある物語でこうあります
あの ヤギなんですけど
生贄にしようといたブラマン人が
このすごい格好いいヤギで
生贄に必要な条件が揃っているヤギで捕まったんですね
生贄にしようと言って持ってくると
ヤギが まず殺そうとして笑っちゃったみたいですね
笑って それからすごい悲しくなっちゃったんです
で 弟子たちがバラモン人で
なんでこうあんた機嫌が良くなって
また機嫌は泣くんですかと言ったら
私はすごく昔 で 何かでき心があって
嫌でヤギを一つ首を切って殺しちゃったんだと
それで地獄に落ちて あまりにも長い年月を苦しんで苦しんで
やっと動物に生まれ変わったんだと
それで動物に生まれ変わっても変わっても首を切られちゃったんだと
それであの山羊の毛ぐらい回数私は首を切られたんだと
でも私のその業は今日で終わりだと
今度私の首を切られて
私は過去で行った善行為によって
私はいいところに生まれ変われるんだ
だから私にとってはすごくありがたいんだと
あ これで終わりだということで笑っちゃったと
だってなんで泣いたんですか？と
あなたの先生やと その人はね
神様のためにと生贄とか言って
変な邪見でね 私を殺して
それからどれぐらい苦労するかと思っちゃうと
もう我慢できないんだ
自分で経験あるんだからと
そんな話を聞いたら バラモンたちがすごい怖くなっちゃって
はい わかりました 我々はもう生贄はやめますと
あなたを大事に守ってあげますと
決して首を切られるようにしておかないんだよと言ったら
山羊が まあまあ無理な話やと
それは それは無理やと
業からは逃げられませんと
でも弟子たちがもう山羊を大事に大事に可愛がって
もうもう守ってるんですね
あっちこっち餌を食べるために連れて行っても
ちゃんと見張りしているんですね
なので ヤギが葉っぱ食べながら
ちょっと崖みたいなものがあって
そこを登ったんです 登ったらそこで突然雷が落ちて
石一つひとかけらが割れちゃって
ヤギの首に当たったと
当たって首がもう飛んだと
ということで まあどうしようもないということなんです
その物語はまあ信じても信じないどうでもいいんですけど
一応この物語で言いたがっているのは
自分がやった行為よりも数えられないほど悪い結果得られますと
それも心の法則でどうにもならない
例えば  80年ぐらいの寿命がある人がいます
その人の最初に誕生する瞬間で
DNA に異常が現れたとしますね
それでその人は一生苦しんでいる
でも  80年間も苦しめなくちゃいけないでしょうに
もし人間も 80年  100年なんですけど
仏教ではこの何百何億年ももう寿命の生命もいるんだそうとね
人間ではありませんだけどね
言うんだから もし寿命は 100億年の生命として生まれたらどうします？ 100億年もあの苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうわけだから もう遊びじゃないと
生きることは早くも輪廻解脱しなくちゃいけないんだと
ああ 楽しいやとかね 生きること
だから仏教は徹底的に悟ることが推薦
それしか道がないんだよと
私はいいことしてるんだから
もう楽しいわとか幸福だわとかね
死後は全然心配してないんだわとか言っても甘い
それは それは悪い方向で
良い方向も同じことなんですよ
たった一人の人間に食事をあげたとしますね
その人はすごく喜んだとする
自分も気持ちよくあげたとする
で 死ぬ時は ああ 自分なりにいいことをしたなと
この間と思って その喜びの心で死ぬ
死んだらその人はもしかすると
もう百億年の寿命ある天国に生まれ変わったとする
そうすると 百億年間もその人は喜びを感じますよ
でも与えた喜びはほんのもうご飯をあげたぐらいだからね
一日で終わっちゃうんです
その人の満腹感 一日も持たないんだからね
しかし 得る結果もご飯一食あげたんだから
あなたもご飯一食もらえますよという数学でもないんです
円あげたら円もらえますよと
そういう数学でもない
だからそれはあんまり計算もできない
わからない とにかくたくさん
善の場合でも 悪の場合でも
一応アビダンマでは計算してみようかなと頑張ってはいますが
もうアビダンマでも無理とはしているんです
まあそこら辺はまあ一応まあなんとなく理解していただければいいんです
それから簡単な経典一つありまして
あるバラモン人がお釈迦様にこうやって質問するんですよ
お釈迦様 人間でありながら
なんで人間には 区別はあるんですか？と
なんで平等ではありませんかと
人間は 人間には上下関係はある
優れているものと卑しいという
そういう区別があるんだ
と聞くんです そこで彼がさらに説明するんです
どういうわけかというと
ディッサンティボーゴートマヌッサアッパーユカ
で 釈迦お釈迦様 私はこの短命の人々が見るんだと
いるんだと 短命 早く死ぬ
それからディーガユカ
それから長寿の人々もいる
これは区別でしょうに
それから 病弱の人がいる
それから全く病気にかからない健康な人がいる
それからすごく見た目が良くないというか
かっこ悪い そういう人々もいる
それからすごい美しい人もいる
それからあまり力がない人もいる
力っていうのは まあ人気みたいなもんで
存在感ですね あまり存在感
存在感がない人もいる
それから堂々と王様たちみたいに
大臣たちみたいに すごい存在感がある偉い人々もいると
お金が財産ある人もいて
財産がない人もいると
それからカースト制ってすごい低いカーストで生まれて苦労している人もいて
ものすごい階級高いところにいて生まれる人もいるんだと
これが何なのかと またあります
智慧のある人を見て 全く頭の悪い人もいるんだと
こうやって人間でありながらすごい区別があるんだと
この区別は何なのかと聞くと
お釈迦様はそれはバラモンあの業ですよと
生命にとっては私のもの
私の財産 私の相続するものといえば自分の業ですと
業っていうのは感覚ですよ
難しくないです そこでその業によって
人間は  何といいますか
分けられますと 人間の区別
区別はその業によって成り立ちますよと
そう言われたら そのバラモン人がちょっとわからないんですけど
その話は もうお釈迦様もまず肯定形で言っちゃいますからね
カマッサカマナワサッタカマダーヤダ
カマヨニカマバンドカマパティサラナ
バラモンよ 私のものというのは業であると
カマッサカ カマダーヤダ
相続しているのは業ですよと
カマパティサラナ カッ業に頼っているんだと
あれ 業に依存して生きているんだと
我々も感覚に依存して生きているでしょうに
それで  カッマンサティバディダイダンヒーナッパニッタタエ
それで説明してくださいと言ったら
お釈迦様はこういう風な簡単な説明をするんです
ある人々が殺生するんだするんだと
生命に対して何の優しさもないんだと
ルッドホーディローヒトパーニ
すごくもう乱暴というか
ルッダっていうのはフェロシャスというかね
すごいもう恐ろしくて
ローヒトパーニもう手がもう血に汚れてるんですね
ハタパハテーニット とにかく殺しちゃう
ちょっとしたことで殺しちゃう
そういうふうに 生命に対して
命に対して何の優しさも親切さもない
平気で勝手に殺すと そういう人々が亡くなると
必ずしも地獄に落ちることでしょうと
いわゆる相手に生きる権利を与えなかったんだから
ものすごい苦しみを味わう
極端に苦のみあるどこかに生まれ変わっちゃうんです
人間にはなりません それで生きる権利も何もない
ものすごく長い間苦しむんだよと
もしそうやって地獄などのところに生まれ変わった変わらなかったならば
もしもその人は人間に生まれ変わったならば
短命と 生きる権利はないと
だから生まれると同時に
もうあんまり命はもう危険で
どんな措置を入れてもやっぱりダメということになります
それがこの短命になる理由だと
それで長寿になる理由っていうのは
優しくて 生命に対して親切で
生命をいじめることを殺すことはすごく嫌なこと
こんなことをやってはいけませんと
すごく母のような心を持って
生命に対して すべての生命に対して生きている人
だから他を生かす人が自分も生かされるんですという論理で
生命に生きる権利があるんだよと認めたら
自分の権利は守っています
それで生まれ変わったら
必ずしも天界に生まれるんだよと
そこでもしかすると人間に生まれ変わったら
まあなんて言いますか
電車に潰れても死なないというか
体の上電車が走ったっても復帰とは平気だと
そういう人はいますよ
別にもう事故を起こしちゃっても
なんのことなく擦り傷もなくもう立ち上がっちゃうとかね
だからもうすごい病気にもならないとかね
そこで病弱の場合はどんな業かというと
生命をいじめる 生命対していじめる
苦しめる 普通よくやっていることでね
動物虐待やら人間虐待
いじめやらね そういうふうに殺しはしないんだけど
もうとにかくわがままで嫌な人はいじめちゃう
だから殴ったり喧嘩したり
そういうふうに体力的にも身体にもすごい不幸を与えて
痛みを与えたりあげたりする
そういうふうに生命をいじる人
いじめる人が一応死んだら地獄に落ちますけど
もしそれはもうなんとか
免れることができたならば
人間に生まれたならば
病弱で体が痛いんですよ
ちょっとしたことで病気になって痛くなって
痛みを感じなくちゃいけないんです
与えたものは味わっちゃうんですね
それで悪いのは割に合わないぐらい受けますからね
例えば一回人を殴って殴ってすごく痛みをつけても
もしその後で人間に生まれ変わったならば
一生病弱でいなくちゃいけないんですよ
あの人に与えた苦しみが
自分が毎日毎日受けなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで健康な人っていうのは
生命をいじめることを何もしないで
武器なんか何一つも取ろうとしないで
その慈悲の心で生きている人なんですね
そういう人は天界に生まれ変わるし
人間に生まれ変わったらすごい健康でいられると
それから なんでこの醜い体で生まれ
醜いとブスと両方があまり差別用語だからね
使いたくないんですけど
まあ美しくない体で生まれると
その人はコーデのほうでウパーヤスバフルよく怒るんだと
それから怒ってもなかなか消えない性格はなんて言いますか
何が深いと言うんですかね
忘れてくれない もう なんか執念深いと
で そっちを怒る また執念深くて
なかなかもう心綺麗にしないんですね
だから本人も苦しいし
でも怒られた側も気持ち悪いでしょうね
自分のことをずっとあの人を恨んでるんだよと思っちゃうと
こちらもすごい嫌な気持ちを味わうでしょうに
そういう人々が地獄 地獄を免れることをできたならば
まあいいことなんですけど
人間に生まれたらみんなに嫌われる体格になる
そこでみんなに嫌われると自分が気持ち悪いんですよ
あっち行きなさいよと言われると
いう人は別にどうってことない
あの人とは一緒にいたくないよという感じだけだからね
言われる側の気持ちどうですかね
ものすごい精神的に苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけない
ですから この美しくない
もうちょっとみんなに嫌われる体で
怒られる場合は怒りと少年無戒ということは業だと
そこで美しい体で生まれる人っていうのは
そう簡単には怒れません
相手が何か悪いことをしたっても
まあ全然自分が怒りません
まあまあ そんな人間やることだからね
なんとかしてよとかね
相手に嫌な気持ちはさせない
自分も嫌 なんでこの人いつでも失敗ばっかりするんでしょうとか言って
自己発火はしない だから人っていうのはいろんな嫌なことを蚊に刺されるわ
もう虫に刺される いろいろ嫌なことはあるんだけど
でも怒るっていうことは
こんな蚊に刺されちゃってとか
なんとかそれを喜んで痛いんじゃないかとかね
すごく明るく楽しく 嫌なことがあっても生活する
それは大変な すごい心の訓練ですよ
そういう人々はどこに生まれても明るくいられる
ですから 人間に生まれ変わったら
かなりきれいな体で美しい体で生まれる
そうするとみんなチヤホヤするんですよ
言うことをやってくれれば
嫌なことはしてくれないわ
もう何のことなく気楽に生きていられます
そこでこの人気もない
存在感もなく まあそこら辺の
まあただ一人で 何の存在感もなく
誰も気にしない人間もいますね
この世の中で有名になるどころか
もう家の人々もあの人いるんですか？というぐらいの感じで
あのいます 私は実際に見たことがありますけど
家でいろんなことを出来事をやったりしたりするんですけど
家の一人のメンバーがいて
誰も顔を見たこともない
挨拶したこともない 家の人々も
もうお客さんも来ましたから
あんたも来て みんなで一緒にご飯食べようとか
そういうこともなく 放っておく
だから 自分が家に入りたいとか
自分で家に入り 部屋に入り込んじゃうし
出かけたいとか出かけていて
帰る時は帰って 自分ご飯食べる時はもう台所に行って用意しているものを食べて
そのまま部屋に入ってとか
そうやって生活すると
家族だったらご飯作ったらみんなで
もうあの人どこ行った？もう早く来いよ
もうご飯が冷めますよとかね
そうやって強引にでも呼んで一緒にご飯食べたりするのは普通なんですけど
まあその人はもう気が向いたら食べるでしょうということで
どこかに置いておくとかね
そういう実際います そんな人気者になるわけないでしょうに
家の中でも人気 もういてもいなくてもどうでもいいことになってるんだから
なんでそんな風になるかというと
その人々はもう業は嫉妬する
嫉妬するという嫉妬の性格
それから他の人々が成功すると得をするともう気に入らないんですよ
なんかケチをつけちゃう
この嫉妬の性格 だから
あの人はすごいかっこよくて美しいですねって
なんだそれぐらいとかね
私ももうもう誰か誰かのことを誰か誰かに言わないんですけど
名前は褒めたことがあるんですよ
私の悪い性格っていうのは
人を褒める場合はない時は褒めるんです
で まあ叱る場合は面と向かって叱りますけどね
で 良いところはもうないところであの人はこういう立派な人だよとか言うんですね
その場合は迫力ありますよ
ないとき言うんだから
おだてて言うわけでもないし
事実を言ってるし 言って大変なことになっちゃったんです
言った時はえらく私のことを嫉妬しただけではなくて
その人のことも嫉妬して
私に何か噂 何かでも作ってでも私まで攻撃しようと
あんたその人のことを気に入ってるんではないかとかね
それはわからないんだよとね
わからないんだからそんなことを言うんだよとかね
それでそうやっても人の肩を取って坊さんで何でしょうかとかね
やっぱりこれはまずいと
これ余計なことを言って
その人はものすごい強烈な怒りを作るんだから
もう私には何のこともないんだけど
その人はどうなるんですかね
そんなこと言って 人がいい人やと言ったら
ああ そうですか それは良かったなと思えばいいでしょうに
なんでそう思うんですかね
ですから 嫉妬するということは大変よくない
あの人は成功しましたよと
あの人は合格しましたよと
あの人作った会社は随分うまくいってるんだよと
ただ ああ これは良かったよと喜べばいいことでね
それは嫉妬する人は何の存在感もなくなっちゃう
生まれ変わると すごく堂々と人気者で
国中知られて みんなにもう大変好かれるような人って誰ですかというと
逆に嫉妬しない人 他人の幸福を素直に喜ぶ
ああ よかったよかったと
そういう人はすごいこの人気者で生まれていく
次に なんで貧しく生まれますかというと
それは人間でいる場合は
誰にも何もあげない シャモンバラモンたちやら他の人々やら
まああげるべき人々はいっぱいでも
ご飯あげるべき人やら
薬あげるべき人やら 住むところをあげるべき人やらね
我々はもう自分一人で生活しているのではないんだから
自分の収入の自分の能力で
まあいろんな人に助けなくちゃいけないんですよ
それは人間の世界なんですよ
俺のお金は俺のお金だっていうのは
これはもうとんでもない話なんです
だから俺の家は俺の家だと
誰にも誰も来るなよと
綺麗な家作ったら友達を呼ぶやなりに
他の人々にそれも使ってもらうなりに
いろんなことをしなくちゃいけないんですよ
自分がお金あるんだったら
自分食べる分も食べて
また助けてあげなくちゃいけない人々に助けてあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
そういうご飯やら食べ物
食べ物やら住むところやら
乗り物やら服やら薬やら
あらゆる人々に与えるべきものを与えてない人が地獄に落ちるのはもう決まってますけど
もし免れたならば 人間に生まれ変わったならば
財産何もない もう貧困で貧しくて生まれ変わる
逆に自分持っているものはあげるべき人にはバンバンバンバンあげちゃう
俺のお金は俺のお金という態度ではなくて
俺はみんなのおかげでおかげで儲かっちゃったんだから
それをお返ししなくちゃいけないんだぞと
仕事うまくいったんだから
すごいきれいな大きい家が作られたんだですと
それだったら まあその分みんなに感謝しなくちゃいけないと
お返ししなくちゃいけないという生き方をすると
そういう人々はものすごい豊かで生まれ変わる
そこでなんでこのカーストの低い家で生まれて
インドだったら状態はいまだにひどいんですよ
カースト差別とは 家にも入れてくれないし
ものすごい厳しい 大学なんかにはこの低いカーストの人が入っちゃうと
もう学生さんたち追い出すんですよ
インドの場合は それぐらいの感じなんですね
まあ日本でも昔はありましたし
で 今にしても偉い人と偉くない人いるんでしょうに
それは何なのかと それはこの高慢
頑固 自分の人格が高慢で頑固で
もうものすごい硬い ですから
挨拶するべき人に挨拶しない
誰がこの人に挨拶するかと
我々よく言うんですね
親にちゃんと挨拶して礼をしなさいと
この現代人のスリランカの子供たちでも
なんで親を挨拶しなくちゃいけないんですか？とか反論する
もうものすごい気持ち悪くなるんですよ
親に挨拶 礼をするのは当たり前のことでしょうに
親が目上でしょうに それで我々は頑固で
私はこそっていう感じで
挨拶するべきところを挨拶しない
礼をする人には礼をしない
そういう頑固で生活すると
まあ地獄は免れたならば
もう人間で生まれても誰にも相手にしない家柄で生まれる
差別される家柄で生まれてしまう
だから名前隠せなくちゃいけないとかね
出身地隠せなくちゃいけないとか大変です
で 逆に尊敬する人は尊敬する
礼をするべき人には礼をする
親にちゃんと礼をする
先生たちにもちゃんと礼をして尊敬して
で 滑らかな人格を持つ人が人間に生まれ変わったならば
大変な階級の高い家柄はすごく素晴らしいところで生まれ変わって気楽にいる
その場合も法則同じ 頑固な人が尊敬するべき人を侮辱しているんですよ
馬鹿にしているんですね
それが尊敬に値する人にとっては気にしないわけじゃないんですよ
なぜかというと 立場上困るんですよ
例えば私の誰どなたかね
あんたなんか誰が気にするんですか
もうもう我々坊主なんか大嫌いやとかね
そういうふうに言っちゃうと
立場上ちょっと困っちゃうんですよ
じゃあこれでどうやって話せるんでしょうかと
今日はと 別に個人的には何のことも
まあそうということでね
個人で言われたらまあちゃんと言い返しますけどね
でもすごく困るんです
その場合は その与えてくれたあの精神的なストレスと困りが
本人は一生永久的に受ける羽目になるんです
そういうことだから 尊敬するべき人
礼をするべき人にちゃんと礼をして
謙虚で柔らかい人格で生きていると素晴らしくて
生まれ変わると高い 家柄のいいところで
階級は高いところで生まれ変われる
そこでなんで人間が頭が悪くなるんですかと
頭が悪い人間 なんで生まれますかね
そこを覚えておいてください
それは人間にいる時は
善は何ですか？不善は何ですか？正しい行為って何ですか？やってはいけない行為って何ですか？人間としてどう生きるべきか
そういう風に智慧のある人々に聞いて学べない
ただ食べて 仕事をして
寝て起きて また仕事をして
また食べて飲んで それで終わり
人生は 善悪道徳も知ったものじゃないんですね
そういう人々は智慧の開発に何もしていない
動物本能で生きているだけ
もし動物本能だけで生きているんだったら
まあ動物ぐらいの知識レベルで生まれ変わっちゃうんです
そこで智慧が鋭い人っていうのは
人間で生きている場合はよく
善って何ですか？悪って何ですか？悪いことって何ですか？我々はどういうふうに悪いことをやめればよろしいですか？自分をどう育てればよろしいですか？とかね
そういう風に知識能力を道徳的な一番大事なことはそこなんですよ
仕事でも金でも何でもないんですよ
親でも誰でもない 私というこの感覚なんですよ
だから道徳知っていくことはとっても大事なことで
すべての知識よりは優れているんです
世界の知識すべてもらっても
道徳がなければ全部無意味になるんです
ですから すごい知恵になるんです
そういうことは 聞いたりする人がちゃんと頭の良い人間で生まれ変わります
という風にバラモン人に説明してあげたんです
そこで見てください こちらでもお釈迦様は我々の生き方
性格そのものを語っています
良いことをするんだそうと言って
お布施だけ言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
例えば嫉妬するということは性格でしょ
嫉妬の嫉妬の性格を持ってる人は
もう朝から晩まで嫉妬の思考で生きているんですね
そうするとそう落ちてしまうんですね
みんなに嫌われ者になってしまうんですね
で あの善行為っていうのは
そういう風に自分の人格は大半
ものをあげることはたった一つだけ
金持ちになる方法だけ
豊かになる方法だけ 他は全部人格なんです
業の場合は ですから 皆様も人格を持ってるでしょう
それそのものがもう次を決める業なんです
自分の人格そのものが
怒りっぽいか 嫉妬深いか
すぐ混乱するか 人格そのものも業なんです
で そういうことで 一応気をつけて生きてみましょうということで話を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます